there was a recent interview with Elon
Musk where he said something my mind is
a storm I don't think most people would
want to be me right they may think they
would want to be me but they don't they
don't know they don't understand what do
you think of that elon's someone that
people probably look up to and admire
aspire to be one of the downsides to
high level genius is you might describe
it as
hypermania so
here's a simple test that people can do
so this is a test of something called
verbal fluency and verbal fluency is
associated with creativity and so a ver
here's a simple verb verbal fluency test
write down as many four-letter words as
you can in three minutes that begin with
t okay that's that's pretty constrained
four letters in t or or write down as
many words as you can in three minutes
to begin with S that's less constrained
all right so there's quite a powerful
correlation between the sheer number of
words that you produce and your lifetime
creative achievement right especially in
the artistic and verbal
domains that's different than vocabulary
vocabulary is how many words you
understand fluency is how many words you
can produce in a given Dey of those
words yeah well people vary to a degree
that you can hardly imagine so some
people if you get them to do the
four-letter test in 3 minutes they'll
write down like 12 words and some will
write down
150 and the ones who are writing down
150 their minds are going at a hypomanic
rate they're just thinking five times as
fast binging yeah without any remission
whatsoever and you know when that gets
completely out of control you have manic
you have someone who's Manic and there's
nothing fun about manic that's where the
word maniac comes from and someone who's
manic has a thousand different plans
Each of which are one sentence long that
they're hyper enthusiastic about they'll
spend every scent of their money
pursuing them and things just go
immediately to hell and so that's the
that's the outer limit of pathology on
the creative front and someone like musk
who's clearly a genius that's what he's
contending with in his internal
landscape now I'm not saying that he's
manic because I see no signs of that but
someone that creative is on that edge or
you see someone like Ben Shapiro I mean
it's very interesting to talk to Ben
because and Russell Brand is the same
way Shapiro speaks I think more rapidly
than anyone I ever met but if you're
with him you see very clearly that he's
probably thinking five times that fast
and that's a lot and when I was writing
maps of meaning which was my first book
I had a very difficult time shutting off
my mind I was obsessed with that book
and so I was writing about 3 hours a day
and then I was thinking about the
material like for 12 hours
as and the thoughts came
as way faster than thinking they
probably came about as fast as I can
read I can read about 1200 words a
minute if the material isn't
overwhelmingly dense and so it was just
nonstop thought for like 16 hours a day
that's part of the reason I started
lifting weights because if I was lifting
heavy thinking 12200 words a minute
while I've got 100 pounds on myly it was
enough it was enough to shut it down
yeah and it was also one of the reasons
that I drank because that was another
thing that would shut it off yeah well I
I think the price that people pay to be
the person that you admire is just such
an interesting frame to look at someone
like Elon Musk my mind is a storm I
don't think most people would want to be
me the price that you would have to pay
in order to be me is not one that you
would but you one of the richest men on
the planet and you get to you know dance
on stage and and release cars that are
bulletproof and put rockets and space
and stuff well yeah but what about all
of the baggage what's the pr what's well
he's also he also appears to me to be
hyper conscientious and I know people
who've worked with him like musk isn't
just a creative genius he's also an
extremely conscientious engineer which
and really conscientious Engineers they
have very interesting Minds I like
talking to Engineers because my
brother-in-law is a great engineer and
when when he understands something Jim
when he understands something he
understands how to build it out of atoms
right like he understands it at every
single level and musk appears to me to
be someone who's this rare combination
of hyper creative but also hyper
conscientious I know that he works all
the time yeah does that sort of uh
hypertrophied executive function help to
Wrangle some of the diffuse Creative
Energy oh we're going to put it into
this one thing at least for a while and
then we'll move on to another thing yes
yes definitely definitely you you Eric
wind Stein's a good example of someone I
hope Eric isn't annoyed by this but Eric
is unbelievably creative but he's not
particularly conscientious and so his
and and I think he found an occupation
where that works extremely well because
he's he I don't know if he's still doing
this but he worked with Peter teal for
quite a long time as his idea man right
and Eric's an extremely interesting
person musk is hyper creative and as far
as I can tell hyper conscientious and
the conscientiousness does Focus know it
it and and that lots of people who are
creative aren't conscientious well it's
rare like if you're one in the there's
no correlation between creativity and
conscientiousness okay so if you're one
in a thousand if you're the most
creative person in a thousand and you're
the most conscientious person in a
thousand you're one person in a million
and musk is probably more like one
person in 100 million right something
like that maybe more but or maybe a
billion right maybe in other news this
episode is brought to you by manscaped
if you are a gentleman who is still
using an old face shaver from three
Christmases ago to trim your gentleman's
area what are you doing join us here in
the modern world there are purpose built
tools for the job and the brand new
lawnmower 5.0 Ultra is the tool that you
need it's got a Cutting Edge ceramic
blade to reduce grooming accidents a
90-minute battery so that you can take a
longer shave waterproof technology so
that you can groom in the shower and an
LED light which illuminates grooming
areas for a closer and more precise trim
or if you just want to do it in the dark
like a ninja would going into the
holiday season you might want to get the
man in your life a gift or hint at him
that he's a tiny bit more hairy than you
would like and the manscape lawnmower
5.0 Ultra is the perfect blending of
these two worlds since we're on YouTube
I can't show you how this actually works
but what I can show you is that
transformation right there that's you
gentlemen unwrap the gift of smoothness
this season by going to the link in the
description below or heading to
manscaped.com wisdom using the code
wisdom a check out for 20% off and free
shipping that's manscape.com wisdom and
wisdom at checkout thank you very much
for tuning in if you enjoyed that clip
with Jordan you will love the over
3-hour long podcast episode which is
available right here go
on give it a tap